[Music]
Both of you are safe. It's the
child who creates the barrier. It
disappears in the middle of a fight that started from us.
Indigestion is also a good thing. That's the line from here.
This
barrier.  I felt so relieved after going on a rampage to smash it.
Leave me alone. Who are
you, Chihuahua? You've
never seen me before. You're the devil, right?
Carve it into your heart.
[Music]
Watch it here  If you want to forget everything and
go back to the demon world and calmly spend your time on the fishing boat, I
'll give you a break. But if you try to do something unnecessary, I'll
kill you right here.
As always, it's not what the hero says.
[Applause]
Weather.  Please don't force me
[music]